but first Caitlyn Jenner's BFF Candis
Cayne has got a new role from Kate's
possible love interest to the young and
the restless' soap star I'm not the kind
of girl that would stay in one place too
long now your friend Caitlyn Jenner is
here supporting you today yeah she said
she'd stop by and just you know see
what's what's going on what is our
friendship mean to you it means a lot
she is going through what I went through
20 years ago and I love being there for
her tomorrow on CBS can't displace a
wedding planner for abbien stitches
upcoming I Do's how important is it even
though you are a transgender woman
having a role that just doesn't even
address it it's huge because it's
starting to rewrite the way people see
trans actors oh my gosh like I just met
her today and the students like she like
opened the door to her dressing I was
like at that moment we're like you're
beautiful no you're beautiful no you're
very you're beautiful and I've seen
they're going all right how long is this
gonna go on for